i think you've said in the past that uh
the movie forbidden planet made a big
impact on you as a kid
oh i love forbidden planet it's still my
favorite science freaking movie such an
important film isn't it
the whole based on the tempest
shakespeare's tempest and and the
monster the monster so
it might even the scariest monster ever
to be in a
in in a science fiction film perhaps
even even compared to alien in some ways
well it was yes i mean of course you see
it today and
[Music]
the film is from 1956 so it's it's
primitive uh
special effects compared to what we do
today but for the time being
uh for for its time there was special
effects were state of the art and beyond
it was they had robbie the robot and
the monster from the id when he appears
in the blaster beams
was an amazing creation you just get a
glimpse of him and his this terrifying
thing and
the sound and all of that was cool but
even more than the appearance of the
monsters there were a lot of scary
monsters in in
science fiction films of the time um
you know mostly giant bugs or you know
godzilla and all that the blob was
pretty scary actually
that was uh that was a pretty cool film
the blob the original blob
um with stephen mcqueen his first role
he was like another
34 year old playing a teenager yeah he
got mine
dad you got to believe me i saw a
monster
[Laughter]
um but but the blob you know was a
creature from outer space and these
other things the godzilla was a lizard
it got radioactive and all that and
the great thing about the monster from
the eden forbidden planet is it is it
came from inside
what was basically a a good man you know
morbius uh dr morbius you know the the
it was a monster from the id it
destroyed an entire civilization
the krill after a million years of
shining sanity the crow could scarcely
imagine what was destroying them and
it's true we all have these monsters
inside us you know if they
if the great krell machine was really
built on earth i have no doubt that we
would destroy
ourselves within within hours i mean
look at the
things that people do in the world even
to this day with uh
you know wars and murders and suicide
bombers and you know there's so many
people who have uh
um monsters inside us
so isn't the lesson the forbidden planet
that you can't deny you can build
this kind of world on rationality and
science and one side of the brain
but if you pretend you've extinguished
the the madness the other side of the
brain the emotional the creative the
darker the you know the the moon as
opposed to the sun and the side of the
brain
and then they're going to create
monsters that'll bash down your middle
door
yeah exactly yeah i mean it's
we're all we're all uh partly beast
the mindless primitive as they say in
that the uh
you know governed by passions by lust
and
fear and rage um
you know and for many of us um
these things are never expressed you
know i i think some of the criminals in
our society and some of the people
suffering insanity
basically lose their power to repress
their darker feelings but the rest of us
you know we suffer these moments of of
uh
anger at someone where we you know we
have this flash of we want to we would
love to kill them or something or
moments of lust and all that and it just
it passes our civilized thing damps it
down
and you know we kick the wall instead of
kicking in our boss's head or or
smashing our rival with an
axe but if we had a machine that
instantly translated all of our
desires our mental desires into tangible
reality um you know it would be a pretty
nightmarish there were 24 hours there'd
be nothing left
no i think you said you were about five
or six when you started writing stories
do you remember what they were about
george
monster stories i think i was a little
older well i don't know maybe it was
about that
i still have one of the earliest things
i wrote which was an encyclopedia i was
writing like non-fiction encyclopedia of
space
and uh basically it was i was drawing
too so i would draw a circle on
each each planet got its own page so i
would draw up like a circle
and color it red and write mars on top
and mars is the red planet it has canals
and stuff
but i was mixing real planets like mars
and venus what planets i saw on
shows like flash gordon and rocky jones
space raider you know so it would be
mars on one page and zongo on another
page so there's this kind of desire to
create whole universes there isn't there
you guys
this would build a kind of universe and
then people
with with things in an exotic universe
yeah i've always been drawn to uh
exotic exotic system which in some
circles has become a dirty word these
days uh that
people don't like to be called exotic
but uh
um you know i i crave the exotic and
i finally got to travel you know i i had
that little five
five block world when i was a kid but as
i've become successful i have traveled
to
to australia and to all over europe and
uh a little bit to
africa the to morocco and all that and
it's
been very amazing on one hand but there
are times i feel
uh that i've almost lived too late
because
it's and it's probably the fault of my
own country or
uh western civilization in general but
like everywhere i go i find a starbucks
and uh you know it's where's the i don't
i don't want to
go to morocco and find a starbucks i i
want to
i mean maybe the people want to people
morocco actually want us
when i went to morocco i turned on the
tv and got the cartoon network and i
went
i don't want to i don't want to see the
cartoon network in morocco yes
no no but they wanted it well some of
them do i don't know but you know
yeah i know what you mean it's it's like
you know you're craving
i mean we both have the same things i i
have to admit i see the contradictions
in
inherently in myself i i go to i go to
distant comfort
country and i want to i want a nice
comfortable
five-star hotel with with room service
and
and all of that stuff but i also want
the exotic bazaars and the strange music
and the
foods that i've never tasted before and
and uh
you know i want something different and
the worlds of imagination
science fiction and fantasy are you know
places where the exotic has lived for a
long time and one of the hands of
writers like jack vance
and robert silverberg and uh you know
some of the
great great writers world builders uh
tolkien
and and all that you know it was i mean
the shire where where tolkien begins a
lot of rings
i suppose the shire is very homey and
familiar to someone
like tolkien himself who grew up in an
english
pastoral kind of 19th century setting
but to a urban kid from bao new jersey
even the shire was
wildly exotic people living in halls and
you know going to ends and all that has
been pretty wild and then as you get out
in lord of the rings the world gets
stranger and stranger and you have these
wonderful places like the mines of moria
and
la florian and and you know rivendell
and ministerith the tower is a
ministerius i want to see all those
places see i want to visit all of them